[Applause]
[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constant tim kissing and this is a
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our terrific guest today is a visiting
fellow at the james madison program at
princeton university
he's the man behind the unity project to
retake the white house which is
something we're going to talk about
and he of course has a distinct honor of
being someone who got cancelled before
it was cool
brett weinstein welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me
it is great to have you here well let's
just for anyone who isn't familiar with
the story which is not many people of
course
i mentioned you being chased out of
evergreen college
with your wife heather who we've met as
well just remind everybody what happened
there because it's such a
an important piece of what what is
happening now and where you're coming at
the current cultural moment from
well i have to tell you this is my least
favorite question in the universe
because what happened
cannot be summarized simply but uh
fate has delivered me some good fortune
which is that now
evergreen is happening everywhere and so
people are more familiar
with the story because it's now
happening to them so
for those who don't know it uh i would
recommend a that they check out
mike nena's documentary on the evergreen
story they could check out benjamin
boyce's
20 part series on the catastrophe
and they could check out heather and my
article in the washington examiner but
the short version
is evergreen was three years early
there was a new president who impaneled
a group
to fix a largely imaginary racial
problem at evergreen and they created a
proposal that would have been
fatal to the institution as that
proposal was
unveiled i opposed it which made me
public enemy number one
and at some point a uh protest was
formulated and sent to my classroom
where 50 students i had never met
demanded my resignation
or my firing protests
erupted across the campus they quickly
turned into riot
the president in his infinite wisdom
pulled the police out and told them not
to enforce the law leaving the campus
to literal anarchy and i was
pursued by people who were
wielding weapons looking for me
specifically it was a taste
of autonomous zones and other of these
phenomena
a bit ahead of the curve wow so
you saw this happen three years ago
did you think it was going to spread in
quite the way it has done or did you
think it was going to be
an isolated incident of madness
i thought it was going to spread exactly
the way it has spread the one thing i
didn't see
was the speed it happened quicker than i
expected it was like it was
a built up kind of pressure in the
system that
hit a phase transition point and
suddenly it was everywhere where i
thought it was going to spread slowly
and you know it would take five six
seven years but it was really like
it died down a little bit on college
campuses
over the course of three years and then
boom the george floyd protest
caused it to take over every institution
simultaneously at least here in the us
and do you think that's partly to do
with what in our country certainly
lockdowns and people being stuck at home
and
loss of work and loss of kind of sense
of the future people seem to have
reacted in that way or do you think this
was always going to happen
well you know i told the congress it was
going to happen when they had me
testify you can see in in mike nina's
documentary that i spell out how this
was
uh what i said there was that i'm
frequently asked about the free speech
crisis on college campuses and every
time i'm asked i tell them the same
thing which is this is not
about free speech and it's only
tangentially about college campuses
it will eventually spill out everywhere
there's no question that the lockdown
and the chaos of 2020 set this in motion
differently than it would have have
occurred otherwise
but the the real issue is that there's
a kind of game theory that causes this
thing to spread
and i want to be very careful about
using the language of contagion because
very often that language
is used to break empathy with people and
i do think that these protests are
motivated by
a correct understanding that the system
is rigged against average people so
the energy that is built up in the
system is about something very real and
i don't want to discount that
but the belief structure of the movement
and the proposals for solutions are
absolutely insane they are civilization
destroying ideas
and they are spreading by virtue of a
um a discontinuity between what's in the
interests of the individual on short
time scales and what's in our collective
interest on long time scales
so in effect people are solving a
personal problem
by embracing this ideology which causes
the mob to temporarily leave you alone
but it empowers the mob to go after the
next
level and um
yeah i guess the short answer to your
question is it unfolded a bit
differently it probably unfolded a lot
faster
but the trajectory was clear from the
beginning because
you know i don't know why this was a
surprise to anyone but colleges
educate people who then move into the
rest of the world and as they do they
carry whatever they learned
in their classes with them so if they
learned good things that's great for us
and if they learned
absolute nonsense about why things
aren't working
and they were told that there was a
simple solution that involved them
tearing everything down and utopia
arising in its wake then they'll tear it
down
but brett those people who's going to be
listening to our podcast who
may have sort of dimly aware of what's
happening in america and all the rest of
it
and black and the black lives matter
movement why do you
think and to use the word civilization
ending for these ideas
isn't that just quite a doomsday
prediction
well yes but when you're headed towards
doomsday you want to make a doomsday
prediction that's
something i've i've got some some
calculations i can show you later about
why that's true
but no it's actually pretty simple so
what we have
is a horizontal uh revolution taking
place
in the u.s and you know it's not just
the u.s you can see it across the
english-speaking world and in some ways
across
western civilization but
this horizontal revolution is basically
infused into everything by virtue of
largely millennials who have learned
critical theory and
its downstream consequences in college
and elsewhere
they've carried it quietly with them
when they were low down on
the the ladder inside of these
institutions
and then suddenly they get the sense
that they are demographically empowered
to bring about this utopian change and
so they've each gone after the power
structures
inside their institutions that means at
least in the us
at the moment we have a problem
everywhere
simultaneously right we're seeing
evidence of this
in the federal government we're seeing
evidence of this in every single tech
company
we're seeing evidence of it in every
college and the fact that i'm saying
every should tell you something right if
this were
simply very popular if it were 70 of
institutions well that would leave us
some sort of foothold because that would
mean that the 30 of institutions that
weren't affected
would have some hope of rebooting the
structure
but because it's every college and every
company
we don't have anything with which to
retain
our sanity or our capacity to navigate
now that could simply be a threat to the
u.s
and it could be that the u.s was going
to hobble itself
by embracing this nonsense and you know
if your engineering school
embraces the idea that you know logic is
a a european kind of oppression that has
been imposed on the rest of the world
which is
literally something that is being
suggested here
if our engineering schools do that they
will empower the engineering schools
elsewhere in the world to take over
because of course the bridges
built by people who don't think such
things will be stronger and last longer
but think now if the us does this if we
hobble ourselves
that leaves an incredible power vacuum
internationally
who is likely to fill it yeah all right
so my point is how is this a threat to
western civilization
very simply right you've got a
effectively
monopolar world and the thing that
constitutes the organizing structure of
that world
you know corrupt and broken as it is but
nonetheless an organizing structure
that holds liberty as a high value that
thing is now engaged in some kind of
ritual suicide
right and i've tried to make this point
to people for some time now when
people criticize the us and and that
their right to the us isn't perfect of
course it's not
uh but you know the the vacuum that can
be created by undermining the united
states
is going to be filled by someone either
the the chinese or the russians or
someone who comes from one of those
countries i can tell you that's not
going to be a pretty place
um but are you are you perhaps reassured
by the events of recent days brett with
uh resignation of barry weiss and andrew
sullivan from the new york times it
seems that
people are prepared now to to call out
some of the stuff to go against
the harper's letter for example are
these steps that are likely to make a
significant impact
or is it just the protestations of the
doomed
wow few hard for me to imagine why barry
weiss's resignation
and the harper's letter would represent
reason for hope
i mean i do think there's reason for
hope but it's going to be a needle that
we're going to have to thread
in effect what we have is evidence that
the battle that has gone on at the new
york times has been lost
and i have to say as much as i i don't
want to challenge
the harper's letter i have lots of
friends who signed it
i think it was more or less a disaster
and not because of the backlash that it
got but because of what it represented
um so i saw that letter as an attempt by
people who suddenly became aware
of the hazard that we face to carve out
a deal they effectively had a kind of
immunity
and they've lost it and they
seem to have attempted to resurrect it
but
in so doing many of our most important
voices people who have been
very careful and courageous in
challenging this
ideology were dragged into a letter that
fused them together with people who
actually hadn't seen it and had been
part of the problem
and then a lot of other people were
excluded from the letter
by design which
means that the letter divided
the small but cogent coalition
that has been fighting against this all
along the letter to great pains for
example
to portray the censorious instinct
as a feature of the right that we are
just beginning to see on the left which
that's not the way recent history looks
here right
many of our best defenders have actually
come from the right and i can say that
personally because i was somebody who
received that defense
many of the people who showed up on my
behalf were from the right
and you know to portray the right as the
problem
is just simply misunderstanding where we
are yeah there did seem to be a lot of
this sort of
well trump's evil but here's my opinion
about other stuff in that letter go
ahead francis
no i was just going to say how
refreshing it is to have you asking a
silly question instead of me i'm
absolutely delighted
that that is very unusual i agree with
you but
but here's the thing bro i remember
talking to you and we sort of both
identified really as disaffected lefties
and heather in particular your college
professors i'm a former teacher
isn't this the fault of capitalism in
that it has presented
young people with an economic system
which no longer works for them
capitalism does not work for millennials
and it does not work for the generation
that came after them
so can we blame young people for going
you know what we need a new system
because i'm excluded from it yeah we
can't blame young people for
registering that the system is rigged
against them
and demanding that that be fixed
and i don't you know i really don't
think most of the people involved in
this protest have any idea what they're
signing up for
they are they are reacting predictably
to a system that has frozen them out of
the well-being that they
helped to create or could create if only
there was a place for them
in society that made sense so i don't
the anger is generated by something very
real i'm hesitant to say
it's capitalism because it's very hard
to say what that means
i think there are things that markets do
that no
other structure can do better and that
for those things
we need to use markets there are other
things that markets shouldn't be allowed
to touch
and we have now reflexively just thrown
markets at everything as the solution to
every problem
and it has caused a kind of um
amplifier of inequality that
uh couldn't possibly have led anywhere
else
but um the the answer isn't simple
were there a leadership structure in the
movement
we could have that dialogue and perhaps
the movement could be
brought to some kind of useful place
where we could actually finally
challenge the things that are so
structurally broken
about our system but without leadership
basically every bad idea gets
incorporated it's like
you know a brainstorming session in
which there's no ability to say no that
doesn't make sense
and um that couldn't be a greater hazard
especially with the amount of power that
the
the game theory provides this movement
and to your point about
disaffected lefties and all i still
regard myself
not only as a liberal and a progressive
but i regard myself as a radical
i haven't changed my political position
because
the reality of where we are hasn't been
altered by this
what has changed is the recognition of
others who
see themselves on the left of who their
allies
might be so in some sense when i listen
to the mainstream left or even the
radical left
i don't recognize anything they're
saying as useful
in the current context so when i say i'm
a radical what i mean
is i actually think we need radical
change in order to survive
that we have run off the end of the tape
and the processes that we were using to
make sense and to figure out how to
navigate
have now created an existential threat
or
they've created a mode that generates
new existential threats so regularly
that we won't go on very
long this way therefore we have to fix
that but
the solutions i hear coming out of the
the modern left at least here in the u.s
are all backwards looking and none of
them stand a chance of solving the
problem
so the thing that troubles me with a
breath and that worries me in the
context of you saying this is
civilization ending is that
uh it's what happens to the people who
dissent against
some of those very bad ideas that are
being suggested
people talk about cancer culture but i
mean it's not the first time this has
happened in history where people who
objected to very bad ideas were punished
for for speaking their mind uh and
anyone who understands that history
would would kind of see where this is
going does that
is that a big part of what troubles you
oh yeah i think
um well first of all i should say
because
we tend to focus on what's active
we are seeing a picture in which the
failure mode that we are headed for
is this uh ever expanding
power of this mind-numbing nominally
left-wing movement but that
mind-numbing left-wing movement is going
to back the right-wing into a corner
and the problem is the thing that these
two
entities are going to agree on is that
the way to look at the problems of
civilization
is race versus race and so my my biggest
concern is not
that the left wins this and suddenly
it's maoist china
it's that we are in some battle between
becoming maoist china
and some kind of uh return to a
race first view of america which is
frankly the uninvention of america
if we are one thing it is a structure
designed to neutralize
these population against population
dynamics so that we can
prosper together and the uninvention of
that is really unthinkable
and why has the left been infected with
these bad ideas because
everybody drink please my mother's from
venezuela i've seen
this happen in venezuela and you know
chavez get elected everybody goes this
is a brand new dawn it goes
well you know everybody on the left lots
of people prominent germanists thinkers
bernie sanders said this is a future it
collapses it implodes
it's now got a larger migrant population
in syria and they don't seem to want to
admit that it's just a bad idea
well the problem is that there's i think
a very simple answer to that question
but it takes a few
hours of background work in order to see
why it's clear right so in essence
um some version of communism or
socialism
arises in the mind when you see runaway
inequality that is generated by a system
with markets in the wrong place so
the fact that people naturally land on
this formulation that if only we could
do
x then our problems would be solved
fails to understand
why x is unstable right so x is unstable
for reasons that inside
of my discipline evolutionary biology we
would call
the group selection fallacy the group
selection fallacy
says that the the central concept of
communism
from each according to his ability to
each according to his need
will not work because we are wired not
to do it
right because anybody who opts out of
that system outperforms anybody who opts
in
so the short answer is if you institute
that system
you will have to institute something
authoritarian and draconian with it in
order to make it work so that you can
restructure people's incentives so that
they do not respond
to the fact that they would be better
off opting out so
in essence the um the economic
formulation
has to come with something unacceptable
that descends into some
dystopia or other by virtue of the
underlying game theory
that doesn't mean that to somebody who
knows little of game theory that it
doesn't seem intuitively like the
obvious answer
and that is a battle we are going to
keep fighting
until we can figure out how to convey
you can't solve this problem with that
solution because it
it won't last right even if you could
make it happen
it will either evolve into something
else or descend into madness and there's
nothing you can do about that
um so you need a better answer hi guys
and welcome to my brand new gaff some of
you will have noticed
it looks incredibly different that's
right palacio del pacioni is no more i
got evicted last week
so i'm crashing on my friend's floor or
as it's otherwise known florio erotico
now we're very excited to have a brand
new sponsor it's expressvpn
that's right expressvpn catchy name
i know now some of you at the back are
wondering what is expressvpn all about
have you ever been on the internet and
looking at things that you don't want
people to be knowing about
we all know what i'm talking about don't
we yes that's right
trigonometry you don't want people
knowing that you're watching and
listening to this show
and you don't want people to find out
about it understandably
that's where expressvpn come in now
there'll be some people
probably the gentleman who'll be
thinking to themselves hang on mate why
don't i just use incognito mode
well let me tell you something your
internet service provider
can still track and find every single
website that you use
even when you're doing it with incognito
mode
that's why whenever i watch this show
i always make sure to use expressvpn
it doesn't matter if you get your
internet from verizon
comcast skype whoever it may be
internet service providers are allowed
to sell your browsing history to other
companies
expressvpn is an app that re-routes
your internet through their secure
servers
so that your internet service provider
can't see
all the problematic interview shows that
you are watching
i'll be honest with you most of the time
i didn't even realize i had
express vpn on it runs seamlessly
in the background you won't even notice
it all you need to do is give it a tap
and off it goes all you have to do to
get this amazing offer
is use my exclusive link expressvpn.com
trigger and you'll get an extra three
months free
on a one-year package that's right an
extra three months free on a one-year
package
that is 15 months
that e x p r e
s s v p n dot com
slash trigger you see teaching kids how
to spell
for 12 years came in useful one day
right so uh before we get into your
political solution
uh which we'll talk about you you
describe yourself as a radical
progressive
right so what is the credible
left-wing solution to the problem of
runaway inequality that you talk about
if it's not socialism if it's not
communism of the type that
francis was talking about well
you know i think the american founders
had a lot of it right and the fact that
we are now running into the
contradictions that emerged in that
constitutional context
doesn't invalidate the correctness of
the values that they spelled out
and the basics of the mechanism in other
words
in the us and in other parts of the
world as well
the key issue is one of the corruption
of a democratic structure so our
republic
now functions predatorily with respect
to the population
uh policy is either um
it is indifferent to the well-being of
people and what that generally means
is that where the interests of
large corporations for example diverge
from the interests of the population
which isn't always but when they diverge
the corporations always win and so that
is
a given people the sense that the nature
of governance
is inherently malignant so they have
stopped participating in it
in large numbers but if you were to
remove
the corrupting elements the things that
have handed power
all to one side then actually democracy
is not a bad way to deal
with this issue that people to the
extent that they can understand what
their interests are
will tend to support them and um it is
the corruption that makes that
dysfunctional that said
we do need to upgrade our structure we
need to upgrade it because the people
who
wrote our founding documents didn't know
anything about
evolutionary dynamics they didn't know
about game theory they'd never seen a
chainsaw
or a train or you know they couldn't
have conceived of a nuclear reactor
or of a process that could alter the
chemistry of the atmosphere enough to
change how much
energy we trap from the sun so the
structure has to be updated for modern
realities and that is that is
absolutely doable but not until you get
the corruption out of the way
and because of this corruption that
you're talking about i presume is what
is crony capitalism essentially whereby
you know it's people you know corruption
between
lobbyists and government and essentially
people's best in interest not being
represented
which makes people disengage from the
system
well you know we can focus on the
details and
there are a dozen mechanisms through
which the water gets through the cracks
but
the the larger issue is if you don't
understand
how evolution works and then you don't
understand therefore
that when you're setting up a system
you're really setting up an ecosystem
in which corruption will evolve right no
matter what system you set up
to the extent that there's some loophole
that allows some
entity to get in to shift policy in its
direction in order to enrich and empower
itself
that loophole will be enlarged and
ultimately it will be the system
and that's where we are it's happened
and what it really takes
is a systems kind of thinking that will
allow us
to frustrate the very process that
causes corruption to evolve and spread
and discover new opportunities
well brett is masterfully setting up
himself for the opportunity to talk
about
his political solution brett you you've
done you've made it impossible for us to
break out of this paradigm so just go
ahead hit us with it
okay um so yes this is um
the plan is called unity2020 and i don't
know how familiar familiar you are with
what takes place
narratively in our system every four
years but
what we have is a system in which um
[Music]
change that is to say meaningful change
that might actually stand a chance of
confronting
the corruption is frustrated at the
primaries that is to say sometimes we
have candidates who actually would be
interested in fixing the system
they are frozen out in the primaries we
are delivered something
either disappointing or false in the
general election
and then we have a kind of incoherent
conversation over it
but those of us who for decades have
looked at the system and said you know
none of these solutions neither the red
solution or the blue solution
actually is going to change anything
going forward we have to break out of it
we are immediately confronted
with the lesser evil paradox
if you vote for something other than the
major party candidates
you are voting for something that will
draw votes away
from whichever of those major party
candidates is closer to your own
position and empower the one farther
away
so your friends are constantly telling
you
don't do that if you vote for something
outside of the
duopoly you're going to empower the
greater evil and then this is going to
be your fault
now there's always been something wrong
with this logic if
for example ralph nader won a single
vote
and the democrats lost by one vote we
would blame ralph nader
for spoiling the election when in fact
the answer is how come you didn't
represent the people and therefore win
in a landslide that's the fault of the
democrats that's not ralph nader's fault
but nonetheless the social phenomenon
of being told that the lesser evil is
your
moral imperative because empowering the
greater evil is unthinkable and if you
can find your way out of that little
trap then you're told well
yes maybe in an ordinary year but this
time the supreme court has gotten
critical and if you vote for the greater
evil
you're going to ruin the country for
decades to come by virtue of the fact
that the supreme court is an appointment
for life
okay so unity 2020 is a structural plan
to beat
the lesser evil paradox and
the idea it's not a political plan it's
an a political plan
um it's a non-ideological plan it is
this
we draft two candidates one from the
left and one from the right
and these candidates need to have three
characteristics they need to be
courageous they need to be capable and
they need to be patriotic
we draft them together under an
agreement that
when elected they will govern as a team
that is to say they will consult on
everything
the president and vice president will
have symmetrical power
and only in the case where there's no
time for consultation or
if they really cannot reach agreement on
what's in the interests of the public
does the president's decision
uh rise above that of the the vice
president and then after four years
the positions would reverse i think i
forgot to mention that the team
would have its positions on the ticket
chosen by coin flip
in the first round so what this does
is it creates a ticket that is a
obligated to the interests of the
american public first
we are picking people who are above
politics
and it uh tends to drain support away
from both the major party candidates
thereby structurally avoiding empowering
whatever you think the greater evil
might be and then we've built in a
fail-safe which is as the election
approaches
if the ticket cannot win we pull the
plug and the election reverts to its
prior state and we go forward that way
so
in this way those who will come at
anything
like this and they will say we've heard
this before it's a third-party run it
empowers the greater evil no thank you
we can say no no no no
it's not a third party and it doesn't
empower the greater evil and we built in
a fail-safe
so that means you can afford to
entertain this
and uh socially you might even survive
doing so
go ahead i mean it's a great idea
and already i i'm on board how do we you
don't have a vote in america
you're not you're not helping brett i i
heard him say he's on board which i
assume means that you will get
citizenship
in time for the election if possible
okay using my venezuelan nationality
because we're very popular over there
oh yes but how are you going to
implement this idea
well you know it's very simple actually
we have things
catch on all the time right we've seen
civilization
revolutionized multiple times in recent
decades by various things and
it reveals that actually especially in
the age of the internet ideas can simply
catch on and spread like wildfire and
frankly if you look at the demographics
of
the electorate our system isn't popular
with anybody
there's nobody who wants to elect joe
biden i don't even think joe biden wants
to elect joe biden
right and you know similarly with donald
trump
everybody who's thinking about these
issues knows that
something disastrous has happened
that has left us with no viable choice
at a moment
when we've never needed leadership more
i mean in the current era
just look at what has happened with with
covet 19 in the u.s
we've absolutely botched the lockdown
why do we botch it well in large
measure because it was politicized so
you need to have leadership at this
moment
the parties have announced that they are
not interested in leadership the
democratic party
is flirting with cynically embracing
this movement in our streets in order to
retain
or to gain power and in so doing it's
going to
create a racial nightmare in the u.s
one that we were rapidly moving away
from since the civil rights movement
so there's no other answer
to the extent that everybody who can sit
calmly for five minutes and think about
the fact that there's no
good solution that comes out of voting
for either of the major party candidates
what other opportunity is there now the
hope is that if people can escape this
mind-numbing logic that tells them you
can't entertain anything that hasn't
been
presented to you by the major parties if
we can get people to see past
that thing then this idea is intuitive
it's constitutional
and hopefully it spreads to the point
that uh it can simply function
isn't part of the problem with politics
brett tribalism
in that you get people like in this
country who vote conservatives always
vote conservative
doesn't matter how terrible the
candidate is same with labor
and same with democrat and republican
well
okay yes tribalism is infused into our
system and i'm not even going to say
it's inherently bad
the tribalism that we have is terrible
and it's going to destroy us but
there's a kind of tribalism that can
function well and
i would just simply say look if you're
focused on the u.s
and how power is distributed in the u.s
but you're ignoring the fact
that a race war in the u.s would result
in potentially
china having uh the top spot in the
the global power dynamic then you're
missing the point
i mean for one thing we have a situation
in china
in which we have something that i mean
really
the closest parallel is something like
nazi germany where
the communist party has imprisoned
apparently millions of
people belonging to a couple of ethnic
minorities
they are harvesting organs i mean this
is insane you want to create a power
vacuum where
that entity is suddenly um without
challenge
on the international stage that's
ludicrous that that's not
that's not a blow against racism that's
a blow for racism
so i don't i you know look
if there was a good answer and it didn't
involve me working 18 hours a day trying
to
capture people's imaginations so that
they can free themselves from this
idiotic system that we've set up um
i would embrace it i would love to sign
on to something else and say unity 2020
was a cool plan
here's a better one let's go but i
haven't heard the better plan
i really haven't so i i don't know what
else there is to do except
um say well it's safe
why not see if we can go the distance
and join up and
talk to some other people um uh bret i i
don't want to skip over something
because you've used
you know terms like civil war race war
kind of almost as a matter of fact
in the course of this conversation i
mean are you saying that that's where
this is headed
you know when i hear myself say
something like that
i i wonder is this a dream am i having a
nightmare is that what's going on
but no i mean it's this is just it's
it's factual right we have every
institution in the country and it's
really
every institution broadcasting the same
crazy message
and the message is so wrong it doesn't
even add up superficially
right communism adds up superficially it
doesn't work because of group selection
problems but
but it's at least a sensible idea at one
level
the idea that white supremacy
is simultaneously incurable
it has to be incurable because if it
wasn't incurable we'd have to ask who
has it and who doesn't
right so the only way we can say hey all
white people have white supremacy built
into them
is to say it's incurable but then to say
well because it's incurable it's
everywhere and that means that we have
to fight it
well you've just told us it can't be
fought so
you know one step into the logic here we
discover
there is no logic here but at the same
time
the underlying logic the game theory
says
well here's how we're going to battle
this out we're going to figure out how
many intersectional points you have
and that's going to dictate how much of
the redistribution of well-being
and power is going to go in your
direction that means that everybody
who's on the losing side of that can
calculate that they are
how are they not going to align right we
have
something like 70 percent of americans
are
white and they're being told that they
have a defect that cannot be cured
there's nothing that they can say or do
that actually makes them okay how is
that not going to create
a coalition that sees race as the issue
and that fights back so we can say
are you catastrophizing by saying that
this is going to end in some kind of a
civil war
i i just don't understand what people
think the alternative is
there's no way that you can set that
dynamic in motion
and have it march this rapidly towards a
group
that large and not cause them to
coalesce in self-defense
we have to stop that it's like it's kind
of like i i
feel like like like night follows day
and
blm follows evergreen this is what
you're talking about this is the next
step
and i agree with you i mean i i think if
if this continues
and if we don't challenge i mean i mean
obviously you've come up with a
political solution i think there's got
to be something at the level of culture
that
that can be reversed as well and what
that is i don't know
do you well i mean that's the irony is
that the solution at the cultural level
is at least the direction in which it
lies is straightforward
because we have lots of people who do
think very carefully about these issues
we have lots of people who
are not signing up for this woke
ideology who are aware
that we have a massive disparity problem
with respect to
things like well-being and power and
they're concerned about it
but something about the modern era has
relegated those people to the role of
influencer rather than leader and i
think this is one of the critical
problems i mean myself included right
what i am now doing with the dark horse
podcast is a matter of trying to get
people
to listen rather than there being some
structure in which the people who know
what's going on can
navigate on all of our behalf
so uh yeah it's a tough puzzle
but i think the solution involves taking
the elements
of a prior system that worked and
pointing them at the problems that we
never solved
that's really the the solution and
we talk a lot about you know the gap
between rich and poor and all the rest
of it and
and all the rest of it and then we have
the problem of automation
and how many people are going to be left
without a job and
also as well what is going to happen to
those people who don't have employment
and the anger that's going to emanate
because of it
i absolutely agree it ought to be a top
priority
this was the reason that andrew yang's
uh
candidacy took off and it's also the
reason that
so many obstacles were put in his way
because he actually was interested in
solving
that problem and the duopoly doesn't
want the problem solved because
it's not suffering in the same way and
in some sense it's a feature not a bug
um
so yeah we have to we have to confront
that we don't
have a choice but to solve the problem
and this time
we could solve it i don't want to say
completely because there will always be
noise in the system there will always be
bad luck but the bad luck needs to be
randomly distributed with respect to
things like race
and sex right to the extent that the bad
luck is predictably distributed to some
populations and not others it's not luck
bret i was going to ask you something
that we often get asked and i
i as someone who recognizes you're very
careful
very intelligent and very sensible and
you know knowing
having met you and and heard you speak i
know that you're someone
i would kind of describe you as a healer
as a kind of entity right
um and we get a lot of people saying to
us well you know you guys are
interviewing people you are speaking out
you are
you're being influencers which is you
know not not the ideal
i hear you but nonetheless what do i do
as an ordinary person
because if i speak out at work i'm going
to be fired tomorrow if i
challenge some aspect of this ideology
or i teach my kids not to buy into
they're going to get
you know problems at school what do
ordinary people do about this because i
see so much of that people just not
knowing how to respond and
i don't know what to tell them either
so this is a great question it is one
with a
it doesn't have a wonderful answer it
has an
answer that i think is compelling but it
involves
swallowing a bitter pill the game theory
underneath
what we are facing and i don't just mean
the movement but the larger
game theory surrounding the way
governance works the way
sense making works all of these things
has
created chaos we are basically
decohering
the incoherence of the system is
eventually going to result in a
catastrophic mistake
and we've seen hints of that many many
times now but we haven't seen anything
that is catastrophic at the level of
civilization itself the solution
involves recognizing
that your individual
well-being is what you are wired to be
focused on
but that your individual well-being is
actually subordinate
in a logical way to the persistence of
the structures on which you depend
so if we keep pursuing how do i get
through next week
at the expense of how do we get through
next year or next decade
we will not get through next year or
next decade there has to be a
willingness
to frankly place that puzzle in front of
people
so that they understand that ultimately
we have to keep an eye on this longer
term larger scale thing or it's going to
erase any protection you manage to
arrange for yourself
so you know i i don't know how useful
my story is my wife and i lost 10-year
jobs
we have no job security but we're doing
all right
so the point is that was a trade and
what we got in exchange for that trade
was the ability to speak plainly about
what's taking place and to bring
the expertise that we have from
evolutionary biology
to venues where actually that's the
important set of questions
in terms of how you build a system that
doesn't suffer these
flaws so was it worth it
yeah i think it was worth it i think
that
even though you know one bad tweet and
i could be unable to figure out how i'm
going to provide health care
for my kids five years from now um
but the ability to speak plainly about
what is taking place
is essential and i think you guys are
doing this i think you are being
courageous and it's unfortunate that
we're stuck in the influencer role but
maybe the the model is this i'm an
influencer but unity 2020 is actually
not an influencer plan it's actually a
structural
plan so the question is what can you do
to step
out of the influencer layer where you're
simply you know
a talking head trying to capture the
attention of people honorably but
nonetheless to capture their attention
to actually doing something
that meaningfully alters the way the
system functions all right but
let me just challenge you on that
somewhat bro are you not being
uh kind of communistic about it in that
you're denying human biology and
psychology and demand
not demand you're not demanding but in
saying to people
um put your interest behind the interest
of the whole because 10 years down the
line
those interests will be your interest
are you are you not denying it
i i deny your accusation but i love it i
love the question because
it's the right question here's the
here's the difference
first of all let me just make a a weird
point
a body like a human body is communist
it functions exactly as the communist
plan
would have it your liver and your heart
agree on the distribution of resources
irrespective of which one is in the
losing position and which one is
generating
so the point is there's something about
certain structures in which
something like communism can work and
other structures where it cannot
now what i am advocating is not that you
become altruistic and thereby sacrifice
in favor of others what i'm advocating
is that you recognize that your
long-term
interest and by you i don't necessarily
mean you the individual but i mean you
and all of your descendants which is
after all what you're built to care
about
that that depends on a certain amount of
personal sacrifice now that is not a
contradiction that biologically makes a
great deal of sense that we see
creatures do this
all the time so um in essence
the point i mean you've you've landed on
it exactly you have to be able to tell
the difference between a claim that does
not add up and is not supported by the
game theory and a
very similar sounding claim that does
because the underlying dynamics are are
different
and that's that's what i'm saying i'm
saying that
altruism doesn't work but ultra
enlightened self-interest
does and this is ultra enlightened
self-interest we are about to destroy
the ship on which our life depends
and brett what would you say to a young
person you know who
wants to change the world and believes
in this ideology and it's like look
racism exists you know there's lots of
stats that can be used to you know to
back up this fact all the fact you know
the gap between rich and poor is getting
ever wider
we need drastic action now social
justice is what's needed
uh i would say i agree with them but the
problem is that you smuggle something in
under the label of social justice that
isn't social justice
it's injustice and so in essence
i would say slow down figure out what
parts of what you're saying
are dead certain and which parts are a
black box that you don't know the
contents of
and figure out what it is that you can
say going forward that doesn't contain
the possibility for let's say a trojan
horse
right once you understand there is
something structurally wrong
it does result in massive inequity and
that inequity
has to be solved or else we're
constantly going to be
uh facing you know a looming french
revolution
so all right the problem has to be
addressed but how do you address it
well you would want to understand what
its nature was how we got here where the
failures of our current structure are
and you would want to figure out
how to patch those things or to update
the structure so that it doesn't fail in
the same way and you know if you do that
you will frankly discover what the next
failure mode is but as with all
prototyping
those failures should get smaller and
smaller with each iteration
ultimately you'll have a structure in
which you can tolerate
the the noise in the system and
basically
you're not going to get 100 justice
you're not going to get 100
safety but you might be able to get 80
of everything and if you had a system
that delivered 80
on every value that you held dear that'd
be pretty darn good
and that brings me very neatly to the
question that i wanted to ask you brett
do you think
with social media the way that it is and
with our brains the way that they are
we are actually capable now of ingesting
that message that you've just
elaborated which is you're not going to
get everything that you want
yes i know i know that we can get there
now you've asked
again an excellent question which is are
the forces that allow us to
see things like this capable of
overwhelming the forces
that try to disrupt our seeing things
like this
and you know we don't all have to see it
enough of us have to see it that we can
actually navigate that's the question
right it's not like every kid on tick
tock has to become a theoretician
but the the fact is
we are told that people are foolish
we are told that they have short
attention spans
we're told that they're tribal however
we have lots of evidence that when they
are delivered
high quality choices when they are
delivered content
that allows us to test those ideas they
don't turn out to be that way
right short attention spans do not match
with the fact that
joe rogan several times a week delivers
us a three-hour podcast with people
across the analytical spectrum the
political spectrum and people follow
these things and they talk about them
so long-form podcasting tells us that
the public isn't what we thought it was
the series that we see
generated on television now on netflix
and hbo and all these very complex
narrative arcs these are things that
people actually invest in
right that's inconsistent with what i
was told about the fact
that people needed to see you know a
30-minute sitcom
and you know they couldn't handle
anything more complex than that
so we see that we also see uh you know
idw style conversations creating
incredible interest
watching 3 000 people for two
consecutive nights
watch uh sam harris and jordan peterson
fight over the nature of truth as if
they were watching
the coolest rock band ever i mean that
tells you there's a great
hunger for anybody who can figure out
how to make sense in this era
people are rooting for this stuff they
want it so
i think i would just trust in the fact
that if you deliver them
high quality stuff they will level up
and in fact you know
your podcast too right you're doing this
right here
we'd like to think so but my point it
was more about social media brett in the
sand
you know our mutual friend james lindsey
was talking about this
uh recently about how the nature of
particularly twitter
but but anything like that really where
yes people
will watch a trigonometry with brett
weinstein
but but way more people will see a
two-second clip of brett weinstein be
being called racist and not analyze it
critically
and and operate on that basis too
it's a great question but here's the
thing at the beginning
that's what i saw right i saw that over
time
the allegations have dropped away people
tired
they stopped playing those cards and
they even started
paying attention to the fact that what
brought me to their attention
actually didn't have a lot to do with
the important part of
the message that i have to deliver so in
essence the stuff that i was teaching
in my classes that my students were
benefiting from and
that made them fiercely loyal and
want to to study more of it those things
are now spreading into the world by
virtue of the fact that there was some
process that overwhelmed the reflexive
process you're describing so i'm not
saying it isn't there but i'm saying
that if you empower other dynamics they
overwhelm
that dynamic and you know look i think
sense making is on the ropes but
it's not dead and there are certainly
places where we see it winning
so greater better sense making is the
thing that we need to amplify
and that results in the positive change
that that we need
but don't social media companies also
have to take responsibility for
amplifying voices that are
divisive destructive and all the rest of
it
because they're the tweets or the the
posts whatever they get the most
engagement
well in in effect they do this to
themselves by deciding
that they are going to um to edit
they then set the impossible problem of
what are they going to edit for and so
for example at the point that they
come up with the insane idea that
they're going to tell us which
factual claims are accurate which
politicians are lying
they um they sow the seeds of their own
undoing because how do you tell the
difference between
something that is backwards and wrong
and something that is so
novel and ahead of its time that it
sounds backwards and wrong
right you can't tell that so either
we're going to frustrate the pro
the process of progress by deciding that
anything that's really far
ahead of its time is going to be just
relegated to the same realm as all the
crackpot stuff
or we're going to recognize nobody has
the formula for spotting
the great thing hidden amongst the kooks
right that's the question
so these these platforms
have to get over themselves they have to
recognize they can't do the job that
they ideally think they want to it looks
good on a on a whiteboard but it doesn't
work in practice
it results in all kinds of injustice and
insanity
and you know look there's a reason that
free speech
has the role that it does in in the
public imagination
and it's because although most of what
free speech
allows most of the stuff that actually
needs to be defended under that banner
is noxious it is the banner that
protects the really important
ideas that need to be protected in order
that we ultimately get to hear them
right so if galileo comes back he
shouldn't get banned off twitter which
likely would happen at this point well
said right
listen brett we're starting to come to
the end of the interview as you know at
the end we always ask our guest what's
the one thing we're not talking
about that we ought to be i think in
your case why don't we go for a couple
okay um there are two things that i
think
haunt many of our discussions but they
rarely show up formally there
one of them is evolutionary dynamics
that in effect we know from darwin that
there are only four characteristics
necessary
in order to get adaptive evolution right
if you if you have
reproduction variation success in an
environment of
limiting resources you're going to get
adaptive evolution when we set up
an economic system or a political system
it evolves
things evolve within it and if we don't
anticipate
that what we write down in our documents
about what we're trying to accomplish
does not have the capacity to overwhelm
whatever niche we have set up
and that we will ultimately see the
creatures that
are supported by the environment that we
created
then we will never get this right
because we will always be fooled by our
own intentions
and we will create structures that
produce
predators of an arbitrary kind so we
need to start thinking evolutionarily
because that's the mechanism for shaping
society into something of a desirable
type rather than
a monstrous type right so just break
that down a little bit
for i'd like to think i'm pretty smart
i'm not sure i got all of that so
you're talking about we've got to shape
the environment the right way otherwise
our intentions aren't going to
materialize no matter what we do
so let's say we're talking about a
political structure
and we know that we don't like
corruption and
we're going to set a penalty for
attempting to corrupt the system okay
now what you've done is you've built a
structure
in which evolution is going to explore
the question
what kind of corruptions are invisible
and what kinds of penalties are
tolerable
from the point of view of discovering
how to alter policy in the direction of
some
private interest once you've set that up
if you let it run evolutionarily it will
create
a genius corrupter right it will
generate something that is capable of
altering the the functioning of the
system without being spotted and with
being only slightly penalized
and then you'll have no hope of
confronting it because it's going to be
better
at shifting policy than you will be at
shifting it back
so what you have to do is you have to
build a system in which there
is no selection that allows for this
process to explore
mechanisms for corrupting the system
right you may have to turn the penalties
up
much higher than you would think so that
any attempt to
corrupt the system is ruinous to the
thing that attempts it
so the thing never evolves to the next
stage because it keeps going extinct
right that's a system that is resistant
to the evolution of corruption but you
have to understand that it's an
evolutionary puzzle in the first place
in order
to accomplish that goal what was the
other thing you wanted to talk about
yeah the other thing i find missing from
all of the conversations where it's
central is
human development so we are having a
very dumb conversation
about the nature of being human you know
at the sex and gender level at the
population difference level and the
problem is that we have a very strong
tendency to look at
adults and to say well what is the
difference between these two populations
right what we don't understand is that
the magic
of humans is that so much of what we are
has been offloaded to the software layer
that is to say to learning and to
culture and
that means that our nature
is radically altered by developmental
environments in ways that may
show up in adulthood as differences that
we will then
attribute to genes because we've been
told that genes are very powerful
when in fact they are not housed in the
genetic layer
and the second part of that puzzle is
things that we find in the cultural
layer though they are not transmitted in
the genome
are often in fact if they are
long-standing
they are virtually always going to be
adaptive
that is to say evolutionary products
that serve the interests
at least of our ancestors if not us so
until we recognize the interplay of our
genetic nature
and our cultural software layer
we will continue to mess up the
question of what can be done about un
undesirable patterns in civilization
and what can't be because we you know we
sort of have this idea that we inherited
from
you know the wisdom of the 50s that you
know genes are these
powerful things lurking inside of us
that shift all kinds of stuff that we
can't
uh imagine they would have control over
and there's some truth in it but
the larger truth is that so much of what
we are
is built into the software layer and the
software layer is
there because it is rapidly changeable
that's why evolution
shifted things in in that direction
within humans and we need to take
advantage of that we need to be
responsible
for um altering things
carefully in the software layer
intentionally in order to solve
problems and to basically liberate
people and make life
better for as many people as possible
rather than
basically throw up our hands because we
are going to claim that these things
live in the genetic layer and therefore
what can we do
that's absolutely fascinating brett
thank you so so much for coming on the
show
if people want to find you on uh social
media where do they go
at brett weinstein on twitter is
probably the best place they can check
out
unity2020 at articles of unity we've
just put out a
new animation people might be excited to
see so uh
come find us yeah and also check out
brett's uh wines uh brett weinstein and
heather haynes uh youtube channel you do
live streams
very frequently which i follow quite a
lot and
once a week twice a week yeah twice a
week the dark horse podcast
yeah uh and it absolutely fantastic
brett thank you once again for coming on
and thank you all for watching
thanks guys oh sorry brett there you go
and thank you very much and we will see
you soon for another fantastic episode
or live stream
take care and see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word